- My lips, honestly, feel like,
like this, like right now.
(upbeat music)
- So today we're wearing
long lasting lip wear
to see how long they actually last.
- We've seen a ton of commercials
on how lipstick is
supposed to last forever.
'Cause that's what we want.
- We're gonna put four
different lipsticks to the test
through a series of Olympic events.
- Event number one
have a damn good cup of coffee.
- Event number two
eat a goddamn taco.
- Event number three
kiss a hottie on the lips.
- We've each been randomly assigned
one of the lipsticks and we won't know
until the end of the day
which one we're actually wearing.
- We can't reapply, or see our lips,
until the end of the day.
- It's Lady Like, and we're about to play
Lipstick Olympics.
(upbeat music)
- Shut up.
(laughs)
I'm trying, okay?
- That feels really dry,
but it feels very serious
like it's gonna stay.
- When she was putting it on
it just smelled like nail polish.
- It's not feeling too bad yet.
I'm pretty sure through the end of the day
it's gonna get a little dry.
- I'm excited, it smells like a Starburst
so I think it's a sign
of good times to come.
(upbeat music)
- I want to eat all of these things.
I'm drinking tea because
I don't drink coffee.
- Did it come off, what?
Did it come off?
- It didn't come off. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] Oh my God.
- [Voiceover] What?
- Chantal's like already in first place.
What the hell?
- [Voiceover] I'll have what she's having.
- [Chantal] It's definitely
dripping on your phone
right now. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] No.
- [Voiceover] Did it come off?
- Little bits came off.
Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Oh no.
- It was like kind of gross
by default I'm in second
place, so that's fine. (laughs)
- I don't feel like
mine's not gonna come off
because it's so dry.
- [Voiceover] Looks like
it's still very dry.
- [Voicoever] It is dry!
- Oh, wait, wait.
- [Voiceover] Oh no.
- [Voiceover] It does crumble
away too.
- Why are we calling
them crumbles guys, that's not a word.
- [Voiceover] They're crumbly.
- Coming in hot.
I have low hopes for this. (laughs)
Ohhh.
- [Voiceover] She has a line.
- [Voiceover] Whoa.
- I am clearly in last
place right now.
- Who has more crumbles, me or Sa?
- I have on the top so
I think mine's worse.
But maybe I just made out
with it a little differently,
you know, maybe I was like.
- [Voiceover] I'm sorry, what?
- All right, event number one concluded.
- [Voiceover] I like to win so I'm happy
that I'm in first place.
- [Voiceover] Ugh.
(upbeat music)
- Two, next event, eat
a damn taco. (in unison)
(upbeat music)
- Nothing, I got nothing.
- I actually don't think
I have anything either.
- I left some lipstick on mine.
- You did?
I have some on the corners.
- Specks again. (laughs)
- It's also on my hands, my God,
what am I, an animal?
- The more bites I take I'm
starting to see crumbles.
- Oh, how the mighty have fallen.
- My lips are gonna be dry
for making out with this guy
and like, I got to be soft and supple.
- I feel like I really have
nothing left on my lips
for Tyler to even get
off, but like I'm excited
for him to have to make out
with me after Taco Bell.
- [Voiceover] I'm like
losing, this is dumb.
I, I quit.
- Event number three, kiss a boy.
- I know him, and we're
gonna kiss, I guess.
(laughing) I feel kind of nauseous.
- That was a breath mint, you're welcome.
- Hey, nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, all right.
(laughs)
- You want to trade it?
- No no no no no.
(laughing)
- Is that good?
- Is it in my beard?
- [Voiceover] No.
It's on your lip, but
you can't really see it,
it's one speck.
- There's nothing on his face.
This is amazing.
- I think there's some
on his, oh, it's saliva.
- [Voiceover] It's like
in between his teeth.
I'm so sorry. (laughs)
- [Voiceover] But it's not on your face.
- You want to try again maybe.
- Oh my God. (laughs)
- Can you see this?
- [Voiceover] A little bit.
- Specks.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Voiceover] Look at that, fantastic.
- [Voiceover] Hope I
look good, I mean, damn.
- [in unison] Oh, okay.
- So I was right.
- You can clearly see
that my lips are dying
of lack of water.
- I can see like the creases of my lips
like very definitively.
- It's like color, skin color,
like a skin Oreo on my lip.
I don't know, that's
just like not a thing.
- This lipsticks incredible.
- Whatever, I had a good kisser
so I'll blame it on that.
- I hope my lips weren't looking like this
when I kissed that boy earlier.
That was probably why he
wouldn't make out with me.
- We did do some Olympic
test to this stuff
and it held up okay.
- It just, it didn't do its job.
- I'm the winner.
- Oh it's like, I'm not beat up about it.
- Lady tip, lady parts.
- Long wear lipstick, Olympic tested.
- Done.
- You know, at first I thought it was
a tortoise and the hare type of situation,
where I'm the tortoise and I'll make it
and people were just over-confident.
But I just ended up being
a tortoise in reality
in that story where I just keep going slow
and I never made it.
- It's here, it's here.
- [Group] It's here, it's here.
- It's here.
[Group] It's here.
- Get it.
- There.
(laughing)
- I think they got it.
- Get it.
- Yeah.
- You get it.
- It's here.